Oh,
I met a dude yesterday,
glow yoga,
just,
he was like,
let me fly you.
What'd he say?
Acro Yoga.
He puts you on his legs like a baby holds you up,
stretches you and shit.
He was like,
Hey,
do you know Bert Kreischer?
I would love to do that with him,
and I was like,
do you normally do like two people on one guy?
And he's like,
what do you mean
get him up?
He goes,
I for sure could not get him up.
That guy was anticipating and human centipede on a trampoline.
Oh my God.
What's that one that swings trapeze,
right?
With the three of you?
I love that.
Huh?
Who Do you think loves him?
Come on.
Do you think
we're not doing
all the answer Tom Lancer.
Arielle answer not to answer.
Do you think you'd love Ari?
I'm not joining us.
I'm missing each other a lot.
My friends,
my friends like me.
You got your crazy.
We focusing on the wrong things.
I spend more time with Ari then.
Okay,
so if one of you tried to attack Ari,
have I have a problem with that?
All right.
We're going to have same shit.
Sorry.
Ari and I have been friends for too long.
Yeah,
you're like,
that doesn't make sense.
It doesn't compute.
This is my friend.
We've got to work this out.
We're going to figure it.
I don't know you as well as I know him for a million hours and then I know you
for 400,000 sure.
Really?
Well,
so what the fuck went wrong?
And that's just how we're all,
we all have to kind of be,
so I don't love anybody anymore.
If one of you,
okay,
if we're on an island,
you got to eat somewhat.
Oh,
you know the answer,
Bro.
You guys are crazy.
What do you think,
buddy?
Let me tell you something.
I'm starving to death for eat.
Any of you?
Yes.
100% I don't know what it's kosher.
Oh my God.
Say Body kill me to eat me.
I don't want to stay alive,
man.
Just a vessel.
I would a hundred percent problem.
It'd be like who you want to kill,
bro?
[inaudible] gets the eyeballs Rogan's ass.
The problem is you don't want to die knowing you ate your friend and it didn't
matter.
We would be don't want to die.
Here's the reality.
If you hadn't said this in this scenario is real,
it's three of us would be so paranoid about you killing us that we would
definitely kill.
You will be like,
everything's cool and you and then we would take rocks.
Just thinking through how do we kill that will be to you about over here for the
last second for it to kill us,
right?
Definitely.
Tonight.
He sleeps at the right time.
I think we gotta.
Yeah,
I'll throw,
I'll get the big rock and you get the other rap.
Seriously,
we have competed against him.
How do you think we would go about killing?
We would have to make him think that we're definitely not thinking about that
and they'll be like,
hey guys,
we're still way,
but we would try to be slick about it.
No,
no,
no.
We'd sit by a fire and then I would go,
hey Joe,
when when you eat marijuana,
does that break down differently?
Your liver?
11 hydroxy [inaudible] real quick.
No,
you got to think that he would be thinking the same thing too,
so he's like,
oh fuck.
I would never turn it against those guys,
but for sure we're not thinking about it.
They think if I could turn her,
get some,
I would.
They're going to,
I've got to kill them.
That's right.
I was going to do it immediately.
Accept the fact you're going to starve to death.
That's where you got to do.
You've got to accept it because if there's only sore for left,
we're in the woods and we're stuck on the top of mountain and no one's gotten to
us yet.
What are the odds they're going to get to us?
What?
How much time we have left,
like 30 hours.
If everything goes great are you would wither away first?
No.
Here's the real truth.
I've just been thinking about it.
He tried to say immediately,
guys,
I see what's on both your minds,
your ball.
Think of killing each other.
I get it from both your points of view.
If we do this,
we're never going to survive.
I propose a truce.
Joe,
go hunt food works,
talk to fire the cook.
Obviously Tom,
I don't know man,
cause football is just trying to think you know a lot about that.
If it was just us,
just us living in the woods world went to shit and we're like on an episode of
life below zero,
we live in some sort of fucking house and we have put together ourself.
We'll make it just like we got through this weird month.
Okay.
This is fucking strange about being a person,
is that you don't know what your boundaries are.
You just know what you do most of the time.
So all of a sudden when something comes up that requires way more of what you're
used to putting in more,
more dude.
But isn't that fucking with your perspective at all?
So you know.